longtemps critiquée voire moqué durant
les deux première vague épidémique le
dispositif destiné à tester tracé isolé
évolué grâce au rétro tracy enfin
peut-on dire et ce n'est pas de nous que
l'idée vient ce système au nom évocateur
s'inspire du japon largement en avance
sur les questions épidémiologique et
l'identification des cas contacts mais
avant de l'évoquer intéressons nous
d'abord autres issing actuelle il permet
d'identifier les cas contacts d'une
personne positive okobé 19 en remontant
sur une période de 48 heures pour les
symptomatique est de sept jours pour les
as symptomatique trop peu efficace car
il faut en moyenne de 8 jours à
l'assurance maladie pour appeler les cas
contact ce qui rend inopérant leur
isolement avec le rétro ce racing on
veut remédier à cette inefficacité
le rétro tra singh apporte une nouvelle
pierre à l'édifice pour lutter contre
l'épidémie il resserre un peu plus les
mailles du filet mis en place pour
retracer les chaînes de contamination
elle est stoppée dans le concret à
l'assurance maladie va approfondir ces
enquêtes autour des cas positifs pour
identifier les moments les lieux les
événements à l'origine de la
transmission du comice 19 et donc toutes
les personnes qui ont été co exposé
jusqu'à dix jours avant l'identification
du cas positifs avec en ligne de mire la
volonté à de les inciter à s'isoler un
travail de détective en somme qui sera
une nouvelle fois opéré par l'assurance
maladie mais qui devrait permettre de
mieux protéger
olivier ferrand s'en félicite on se met
en ordre de marche pour aller chercher
toutes les chaînes de contamination se
trace singh rétrospectif à la japonaise
est beaucoup plus efficace
on va remonter aussi loin que possible
une bonne chose a priori mais pourquoi
avoir attendu si longtemps
et bien parce que le dispositif n'est
valable et efficace qu'au dessous d'un
seuil de circulation ducobu 19 qui
correspond à peu près à 5000 cas par
jour
si on en croit le communiqué de presse
publié par l'assurance maladie des
conditions réunies par la france depuis
la semaine dernière
l'assurance maladie pourra compter
également sur l'aide des agences
régionales de santé dans certaines
situations comme par exemple
evènement trouver ne permet pas
d'identifier nominativement toutes les
personnes un interrogatoire qui
s'annonce donc plus coriace pour la
personne contamine les questions sont
réajustés plus intrusive puisque la
seule question ne consiste pas à savoir
quelle personne on aurait pu contaminer
mais dans quelle situation dans quel
lieu à quel moment cette efficace pour
délier les langues quand la
contamination a eu lieu lors d'un
événement interdit ou sans que les
parents soient au courant
un dépistage plus agressive donc et qui
peut poser question si on s'attache au
respect de la vie privée on nous forcera
entre guillemets a détaillé avec
exactitude nos agendas
en cas de contamination mais le rétro ce
racing semble faire ses preuves en
france 60 départements et 12 agences
régionales de santé le déploie depuis la
mi juin
en loire atlantique notamment où
l'expérience a repéré davantage de
contacts à risque de contamination
onze cas contacts en moyenne contre 3 4
et dans le cadre du trading
un classique méthode efficace que le
gouvernement veut consolider pour éviter
une nouvelle vague avec la menace du
variant indien reste à savoir à quel
prix pour les libertés individuelles